I have tenitis and been taking an E300. I know there's a rife program, but it's eight hours. Should I just run a couple hours during the day?
Will it help if I never get through the entire program? Of course, I'm running my cancer programs.
Yeah, so if there's a program that you want to run on the rife that's too long, just running any time on that program can be helpful.
Tenitis is a difficult thing to treat. Now, I recommend the Delta to go tree at all. That's what say the anano E300 or our apop E is the same thing.
But tenitis is, so remember the inner ears are certain parts of your body that you have what are called terminal vascularization.
Meaning that you don't have an asthmocene vessels. Meaning that you don't have other vessels that feed the area if a vessel gets constricted or blocked.
So in your heart, you have terminal vessels. In your ear, you have terminal vessels.
And your vascularization can be affected by a lot of different things. Infection, H by Laura, Lyme disease, heavy metal toxicity, sympathetic overdrive, your sympathetic nervous system causes constriction of the vessels.
That's what increases your blood pressure. And that can lead to a lack of oxygen to the auditory nerve.
So the auditory nerve in your ear is integrated by goes back to the temporal lobe.
So if you have damage of the nerve back to the temporal lobe, the chance of that regrowing is very, very difficult.
Now, the benefit of taking Delta Toko Trinol for tenitis or for your heart is because it helps open up those terminal vessels.
So I've had people with tenitis that have started with Delta Toko Trinol and they literally cure their tenitis. I've had people with complete loss of hearing in one ear and I put them on the Delta Toko Trinol, which is the inner part of the vitamin E molecule.
And they got their hearing back completely.
So, but I've also had people with tenitis that I just couldn't bunch ever never did. It seemed like no matter what we did, it did it help.
Not that it helped.
I do know that you have to look for inflammatory other causes of inflammation with tonight is too. So you do getting a Syrix array ten can be helpful for that.
But again, there's some people if you have damage all the way back to the temporal lobe, it's pretty hard to fix that.
Now, there are some temporal lobe brain based therapy exercises that you can do.
And my wife actually has tonight a such as way to put some of those things together. So when I do, I will actually post it up on our member site where everybody around create a blog post about it.